hey youtubers it's Charlie so Walking
Dead is back [ __ ] went crazy in the
first episode a few knows like an hour
and a half like most premieres and most
finales so I feel like there's a whole
bunch of talk about something to do top
10 moments just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet new
round of the giveaway also starts now -
it's a $20 Amazon gift card just like
normal all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so everybody grab the bull by the
nutsack let's do this number 10
meet the super horde inside the quarry
some people call it the super pack you
call the super horde or just the Horde
the way they explain it in the episode
is that originally there was a camp down
there that died it slowly attracted more
walkers the noise attracted even more
and it just grew and grew like this
dying star until you have a seat like an
ocean full of walkers so really the safe
zone people and Rick's group didn't have
anything to do with trapping them down
there but like Rick says we need to get
them before they get us just kind of
teeing up a nice metaphor for their
encounters with potential future groups
this season especially the wolves on the
number nine
Rick versus Ron so this is Pete son he
is in total teenage dick mode in the way
that Jesse explains it later is it just
like he can't hear anything from you
like his brain will just shut it down it
doesn't matter how much sense you're
making this is actually a really good
PSA for anyone that works with children
or is a teacher or has ever had to deal
with the angry parent of a child it
doesn't matter if you're in the right or
not if you get into an encounter with a
child and they somehow feel hurt you
will always automatically be wrong no
matter how much sense you're making so
if you ever find yourself tackling a kid
to keep him from falling into a ravine
full of walkers just say I hope you're
okay and slowly back away on the number
8 though everybody flips their [ __ ] in
the first 10 minutes of the episode so
this footage that we're actually
watching this opening scene is right out
of the trailer with Carter Ethan and
Brees character yelling we're not ready
we're not ready
everybody just flipping out this was
probably my favorite opening to a first
episode of any season like when you look
at all the premiere episodes and you
look at the first scene from each of
those episodes this is definitely the
best and it definitely looks like they
didn't leave any money in the bank when
they set it up I mean most of these
walkers are probably duplicated in CG
like they they probably like a bunch of
people and practical effects
they'll probably also have a bunch of
them that are just duplicated they just
copy and paste with really expensive
special effects software crowd
duplication is like a really big thing
when you have giant crowd scenes and you
have like figures that are really really
tiny you don't need to get close-up
shots of on the number seven everybody
hates father Gabriel so there was this
really funny moment The Walking Dead did
this fan premiere on Friday night just
like a couple days ago the whole cast
went out to Madison Square Garden they
did this this big premiere they aired
the first episode a couple days early
for a bunch of fans Seth Gilliam the
actor that plays father Gabriel walks
out on stage everybody just boos the
[ __ ] out of him I mean obviously they're
booing for his character everyone loves
Seth Gilliam he's a great actor father
Gabriel his character however sucks
something fierce is like the game of
thrones Joffrey affect if an actor is
supposed to make you hate his character
and you hate the character he is
completely 100% succeeded in his job so
Deanna shuts him down
Rick shuts him down really fast during
the big group meeting when they're
trying to find people to help speaking
of help though on the number six Abraham
and Sasha just two of a kind both going
a little bit crazy
although Abraham is kind of headed in
the downward spiral Sasha is getting a
little bit better she's actually a
little bit less crazy than she was last
season remember when she used to lie on
top of those Walker piles yeah that's
crazy Sasha like nestling up to the
barrel of a gun
24/7 this version of her just seems a
little more present mentally like she's
more present in the moment
Abraham however seems like he's headed
in the opposite direction let me ask you
something you doing this because you
want to die don't you kind of feel like
the way he says that he's trying to get
her to validate the way that he feels
like he kind of wants to die just a
little bit grabbing the bull by the
nutsack Abraham totally does not
disappoint to like you kind of see him
like going a little bit crazy when he's
trying to bury the bodies - they're just
drinking that whiskey looking at the
ring I think he's just remembering his
family the camera lingered on that
wedding band for so long there's no way
it was a coincidence moving along with
characters getting more and less crazy
at the same time number five
Eugene's smile thank God nothing
happened to your hair Eugene and Tara is
like the best friendship on the show
right now
next to Carol and Daryl we really didn't
get like a Carol Dale moment but we had
that amazing Eugene moment just the
smile on his face
that is the best smile I've ever seen on
the walking dead mostly because it's so
unnatural but in a nice contrast to that
number four you have Nick and Glen who
apparently are best buds now they had a
really nice arc in the episode like
between the flashbacks in the the
present-day scenes they just things get
slowly better between them like the last
flashback we have with them Glen it's
like I'll tell you when and then we'll
make it right so awesome seeing Nick
selflessly save Heath who's one of the
new comic book characters then Glen
immediately saved Nick this will kind of
tie in with that final scene with Rick
and Morgan where he's like some people
are gonna die no matter what it seems
like Nick is not one of those people
like he realized what was up as opposed
to Carter who kind of never really truly
figured things out on the number three
though
Morrigan slowly feels the group out
especially in the flashbacks even though
it's really satisfying seeing him you
know quote-unquote
get to know Rick again it was just fun
seeing him meet the other members of the
group like Carol for instance did he
used to be a police officer too
why would you say that just because you
have that look about you you look like
you're always ready Melissa McBride is
so awesome as Carol now just like the
subtle way she has about her where it's
like this really creepy housewife that
could just stab you in the face at the
drop of a hat don't you just get the
feeling now that she's crossing into
Daryl Dixon territory where it it almost
feels like the fandom would just
absolutely quit the show if they were to
die like she's that popular now it
doesn't necessarily make her immune but
I definitely think the writers are gonna
keep her around as long as possible
I mean she's one of the most interesting
characters in the show why wouldn't you
keep her around Carol really didn't have
a whole lot to do in this episode but I
felt like that was her big scene on the
number two though Rick's gambit to take
the super hoard away from the safe zone
as he explains it on this map here like
there's a giant fork in the road they're
trying to take them down the fork that
goes away from the safe zone the other
one goes right towards it so they just
had they had to create this big barrier
here and they have to keep them from
turning around from getting distracted
you think it's been in that big moment
and in the way they bounce back and
forth between that Morgan scene with
Judith which is so perfect some people
are gonna die no matter what BAM
face bit down you go Rick snaps his neck
you need to be quiet now such a perfect
job editing even if you didn't like the
black-and-white the way they edited that
scene was just
faked and for the most part it kind of
works I mean it's very suspenseful the
way they cut it they make it seem like
at any moment the walkers might break
down the barrier and go towards the safe
zone but Daryl Sasha and Abraham leading
them away when all of a sudden number
one WTF moment the giant horn sounds
leading them back towards the safe zone
in like the whole line turns sideways so
it's like they're not single-file
anymore now they're super spread out so
it'll be almost impossible to take them
down in an easy way
right off the bat let's talk about who
we think this is it's probably the
wolves in one of their 18 wheelers that
sounds like an 18-wheeler horned like a
really big car horn not a little sedan
just a giant freakin 18-wheeler horn
second big thing now in addition to like
whatever threat now is creating this
noise
you have a super horde that's super
spread out lengthwise it's a lot easier
to deal with walkers when they're
single-file like you can just take them
down three or four at a time
but when they're spread out like that is
a lot harder to manage so the the teaser
for the next episode is just setting up
that a bunch of walkers might make it
inside the safe zone it's gonna be too
much for them to defend the entire wall
so if you want to read along in the
comics I'd recommend reading no way out
like the collected edition here's the
debate we need to have in the comments
though who is blowing that giant car
horn is it the wolves or is it someone
from the safe zone like I said I feel
like it makes the most sense that it be
the Wolves I don't think it's Ron or
some other random safe zone person but
here's what's going on so New York Comic
Con just ended today there's still a
couple of trailer videos that I need to
get through I'm gonna try and do a Q&A
for this tomorrow for the Walking Dead
episode I need to get back on track with
that I didn't do q and A's for fear The
Walking Dead so hopefully all that stuff
will get done on Monday if I need to
I'll just push my Gotham video to
Tuesday morning before the flash so just
be sure to follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates on that usually I'm
really good about posting where I'm at
with videos at any given time but
overall the episode was great I love the
way they edited I always like it when
they try new editing techniques as long
as they don't do this black and white
flashback every single episode I think
it'll be fine I will go ahead and say I
think that this episode is better than
the season 5 premiere but you guys can
let me know like which of the premieres
is your favorite going all the way back
to season 1 personally season 5 was my
favorite before this but now this is my
new favorite this
especially because they killed ethan
embry I'm so happy that he's not gonna
be around this season just the look on
his face he was such a debbie downer
just in case you guys haven't seen it
I've posted a couple New York Comic Con
videos you can click here for the
legends of tomorrow Comic Con panel and
you can click here for the viral teaser
from Batman V Superman thank you so much
for watching everybody
what's at 5:00 I'll see you guys
tomorrow